will Kane Fox and Friends Weekend
co-host this is is really disturbing
stuff I mean the Chinese government has
done everything in its power to
Stonewall investigations we know that
but now we're learning that according to
congresswoman Nicole malliotakis Dr
Anthony fauci actually could be at the
center of what she calls one of the
biggest cover-ups in American history
yep yep and then I would only add to
what Jim Jordan was saying there and yet
Julie still today if you question
fauci's sainthood you are a wing nut
Redfield again it's worth underlining
and highlighting former director of the
CDC laid out a couple of really
fascinating points uh Julie that I want
to reiterate first of all in September
of 2019 that Wuhan lab changed three
protocols that implied guilt they they
deleted the strains the codes of the
virus they changed from civilian to
military
oversight and and then they brought in a
contractor a civilian contractor to
change the ventilation system every one
of those pieces of big circumstantial
evidence pointing to their own guilt
that it was a virus created in a lab and
yet then we see the cover-up you point
out fauci in League with social media of
course paints anyone who points to that
truth as a conspiracy theorist and then
again pays off nine million dollars in
Grants to two scientists who said hey
this looks like it was made in the lab
they flip all of a sudden they're on the
same script as every other scientist out
there saying it's of natural origin then
the most fascinating question Julie why
and that's what maliotakis gets to the
reason why fauci would go to Such Great
Lengths is because of his own
culpability what he's covering up is his
guilt and helping fund this worldwide
pandemic the more interesting question
isn't fouchy because that seems obvious
to me is why did the entire scientific
Community rally behind fauci and that
gets us to well masks lockdowns vaccines
it's because science is lost and it is
not science it is scientism and it
followed the saint fauci wherever it
told them they should March that's why
the scientific Community fell behind a
guy who was covering up his own
culpability the most disturbing in this
is I cannot understand I cannot grapple
with the fact that the American public
was not informed of this known Theory
years ago it's not like it was just
discovered they've known for years this
after millions of people lost their
lives and yet still there's a denial
from the White House the there's a
denial from fauci that he ever believed
that it could have potentially come from
a lab and then we hear about this nine
million dollars which was a grant to
research for the research doctors to go
forward to that paper which was never
even forwarded to the CDC director I
just none of it adds up
the way it adds up though I think it
does add up Julie it adds up to life it
adds up to live cover up yeah lies in
cover-up
yeah it's it's really disturbing and I
mean thank God that there is this
hearing right now if it weren't for this
hearing this would have been swept under
the rug and then you have to wonder what
else is being swept under the rug if not
for Republicans holding hearings to come
up with answers yeah
all right yeah I'll say this Julie so
why is this important important it's not
just retrospective gain a function
research is still taking place in
unsecured labs in China to this day gain
a function research is part of
scientific protocol that's one two as
you point out if you went to these links
to cover up this story right what else
did you cover up science doesn't by its
very nature and definition shouldn't and
it doesn't in the popular Consciousness
I think anymore demand
unblind Faith all right that is not
science gotta switch gears here now uh
President Biden's disastrous withdrawal
from the Afghanistan front and center at
a house hearing yesterday lawmakers
looking for answers here as well there
were some really powerful stories from
those on the ground during the two weeks
of this chaos which occurred in August
of 2021 one witness a marine sniper who
lost an arm and a leg in a suicide
bombing at the Kabul Airport he gave
gut-wrenching testimony about the
moments following the explosion that
left third 13 U.S service members dead
something he said could have been
prevented
Flash in a massive wave of pressure
I'm throwing 12 feet onto the ground but
instantly knew what had happened I
opened my eyes to Marines dead or
unconscious lying around me
a crowd of hundreds immediately vanished
in front of me and my body was
catastrophically wounded with 100 to 150
ball bearings now in it plain and simple
we were ignored
our expertise was disregarded no one was
held accountable for our safety
ignored can you imagine your son your
husband
fighting overseas and you know that they
could have protected themselves that was
marine sniper Sergeant Tyler Vargas
Andrews remember that name he's a hero
he described how he and his fellow
Marines indefinitely identified a
suicide bomber before he killed 13 U.S
service members he said that no one in
the chain of command will even knew who
could give the Sharpshooters the okay to
take out the bomber before he got away
with this grizzly attack he says plain
and simple we were ignored our expertise
was disregarding disregarded this is a
glaring example of how the Afghanistan
pullout ordered bar our president put
our troops at at grave risk
absolutely he said he identified along
with other soldiers they had a
description and he identified the
suicide bomber hours before this this
attack took place they had a description
they identified him and they asked for
permission to engage and they were
denied that permission and when asked
why the answer he was given was I don't
know and therefore they never were
allowed to engage the suicide bomber
disappears once they get into the crowd
hours later what happens as he describes
right there you know Julie it's just you
can listen to and talk to the soldiers
on the ground almost to a man and I've
gotten to know a few of these guys who
for example were involved in operation
Pineapple Express Scott Mann who
testified yesterday as well and when you
see the competency Julie of the men on
the ground when you see the competency
of the soldiers who stepped up in the
void of the federal government you see
what could have been but in in in in
alternative in reality unfortunately
what we had was incompetence in
leadership if you have have competency
on the ground but you have a catastrophe
in reality what you have to see then is
you have incompetency at leadership
driven by I don't know failure fear
driven by incompetence who knows what it
is but it adds up to failure and it
lands squarely on leadership it lands
squarely on you have to the bat the buck
as Harry Truman said with the sign on
his desk the buck stops here the buck
passes to the ultimate leader and that
is the president of the United States
you're absolutely right will Kane well
said thank you so much great to see you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis